you may not believe it  but there is magic all around us  there are times it can be hard to find  did you bring your garbage to school  but sometimes stuff the magic  finds us look at you  number casey so cute i'm so red  how big is he gonna get that depends  doesn't it unless  on how much you love him i wish you were  big and strong  and the world could nervous  [Music]  we're gonna be late for school  bless you  [Music]  why don't we get you on the scale here  bud  i'm just gonna write heavy  what if you found someone who made you  feel like you could do anything  [Music]  [Music]  clickers  [Music]  oh  well you don't see that every day maybe  it's time to feed him